well I have to give credit where credit
is due at least Alexandria Ocasio Cortez
is honestly radical because she might be
the one Democrat who voted against
reopening the government in reality all
of the Democrats including Nancy Pelosi
voted against reopening the government
when they voted for a funding bill that
does not include five billion dollars
for border security this is very simple
president from has said we need border
security I'm not asking for a lot of
money the whole federal budget is going
to be four point four trillion dollars
you've already voted for fences and
walls along the border Chuck Schumer
Hillary Clinton Barack Obama all voted
for it give us just a little bit of that
every other Democrat wants to pretend
that they want border security but for
some reason they don't want the border
wall which is not terribly expensive
it's obviously moral it obviously works
where it's been implemented its reduced
illegal crossings up by upwards of
ninety percent what Alexandria Ocasio
Cortes is saying is nope I don't want
any of that and the reason I don't want
that is because I want to abolish
immigration enforcement that's a radical
agenda Democrats played with it all
throughout the midterms they backed off
of it when it seemed unpopular but at
least the Socialists from New York is
giving us an honest debate let me ask
you something though Alexandra Acacio
Cortez no matter what you think of her
no matter what you think of her policy
she is popular people listen to her
especially people in the younger
generation what have you make of the
fact that she has this microphone and it
seems like a lot of young people are
willing to listen that's right she
unfortunately her generation and my
generation overwhelmingly now the
majority of us identify as socialists
the good news is that a very small
minority of us can actually define what
socialism is so there is some hope
possibly for the future she's an
attractive candidate she's compelling
she's a lot better on television than
Bernie Sanders she's even a little
easier on the years her proposals are
economically incoherent she can't give
any explanation for them it's impossible
to defend how you want to have a nation
but you don't want to be able to protect
the borders of that nation that's the
primary function of government is to
protect its people and to protect its
integrity and its sovereignty now she
can't give any explanations for that but
she comes from a
Oh generation we live in a shallow age
of politics and she's doing a lot better
job at this than Nancy Pelosi
and her fellow Democrats well back to
ice for a second you know there's
there's still this this belief out there
that ice is primarily just raiding homes
of hard-working little illegal
immigrants and just throwing them out of
the country the fact is is that that's
not the priority that they're typically
going after people that are committing
crimes and a lot of the crimes that
they're preventing are crimes in these
communities like Acacio cortezes
District in the Bronx which is a heavily
immigrant community does she just ignore
your telling me you could you could go
through a whole list of the victims of
people who come here illegally but what
she's talking about is really a broader
principle she's targeting immigration
enforcement as an agency and really
she's targeting immigration enforcement
as a principle do we have the right to
be a country or not do we have a right
as a people to say we don't want certain
people to come in here we don't want
certain people to access our very
generous welfare and entitlement system
we don't want certain people to come in
here and vote and change our laws and
especially at a time when the left in
this country is discouraging
assimilation do we have that right or
not Alexandria Ocasio Cortez is going
out there and saying absolutely we do
not and that's the debate that we're
going to have let's talk about Kamala
Harris here for a minute
officially running for president for
2020 she made that announcement earlier
this week do you think she's going to be
able to get the votes well I don't I
think at this point I'm gonna declare
that I'm running in the 2020 Democrat
primary field I think I'm the only
person in the country who isn't running
she has a bad strategy at the moment
which is to hire all of Hillary
Clinton's former campaign team I wonder
if Walter Mondale's team or Wendell
Willkie steam we're not available
doesn't make a lot of sense to hire
losers to staff your campaign right now
Kamala Harris is coming out of the gate
and she's running heavily on identity
politics she declared on Martin Luther
King Day
she is adopting Oakland as her hometown
even though she grew up from the age of
seven to the age of 18 in Canada she's
constantly talking how she went to an
historically black college she is she
had that mood mix
video we're just dancing along -
Funkadelic and maybe she's 40 of them
running and I mean the race to the left
for the primary is just going to be
hysterical I mean they're gonna go so
far left they're gonna fall over the
edge Michael thank you so much for your
time we do appreciate it good to see